hey guys I have another video for you I want
to talk about the difference between burning
calories in general and burning fat calories isn't
the goal to burn fat calories so many people say
well I'm going to go and exercise I have to burn
up my calories I just ate you know they're in the
calorie burning but what kind of calories are
they burning typically when you actually go an
exercise it's very rare that you're going to burn
any fat calories at all in fact go ahead and try
this experiment go ahead and work out three
hours weigh yourself just before the workout
and right after and see how much weight that you
lost it'll be zero because the calories that you
burn when you exercise are mainly mainly sugar
stored sugar calories in the form of glycogen
glycogen is a bunch of sugar molecules attached
together glucose molecules attach together as one
unit and that's called glycogen so you store it
in the muscle and you store it in the liver okay
so when you exercise you basically tap out your
glycogen reserve so you deplete it and then you
think oh wow it burned out my calories I'm I'm
going to lose weight right well it depends what
really determines if you to burn fat calories
is if you keep your dietary carbohydrates or
glucose really low the big mistake that I see when
people workout is they'll they'll eat some fruit
after the workout they'll drink a protein sugar
shake they'll drink some juice after the workout
Gatorade with the glucose and fructose you know
as their electrolyte and it pretty much nullified
any benefit of exercise because as soon as that
sugar goes in there that exercise you're going to
basically burn up that sugar instead of your own
fat okay if you exercise in the absence of glucose
or sugar diet diet wise you will trigger hormones
that will then work for you 48 or 24 to 48 hours
later okay when you're sleeping so that's really
the benefit of exercise it's in the recovery later
not during the workout but if you have any sugar
before during or after you pretty much are not
going to be burning this type of calorie right
here and I think people give this give the wrong
importance to calories as a whole if they will
eat everything in moderation eat a less and you'll
lose weight because of course you know calories
in calories out well no that's not how it works
and if you avoid fat calories they have the most
dense dense calories or more calories per unit
than carbs or protein but the fat calories are
neutral when it comes down to triggering insulin
so when you eating less calories it really talks
about what are you what less what type of calories
are you eating less of if you're eating less of
carbohydrate calories then you're good if you're
eating less of fat calories in keeping your
carbohydrates high it's very very bad you're
not going to lose fat so it's not about burning
calories it's about burning fat calories to do
that you have to keep your glucose and your sugar
as low as possible I like to recommend keep it
below between 20 and 50 grams if you really want
to lose weight keep it below 20 okay and that's
what's going to help it's not about eating less
calories it's not about exercising it's about
understanding the whole picture hormone Lee
thanks for watching hey you probably already
subscribed but if you haven't press this little
button down below and I will keep you updated